well there's nobody here
the stream now features weird
Oh what's up Joey nierotko what's
happening
Hyperion what's up I felt like doing a
random Q&A like no particular reason
just I thought it'd be cool like I
thought it'd just be fun so I'm doing it
like a random Q&A I thought it'd be
interesting you know to like just like
randomly just start talking oh man I
thought it'd be interesting but nobody
I'd give the videos you know like in
like you know like I give the livestream
you know like an hour or something like
that to give people time to show up and
all that kind of good stuff but ya see
people are certain to show up now like I
usually give it a while you know give
people a chance to show up and so on but
I figured I'd just like stream now and
just see what happens and I thought it
was gonna be kind of a funny idea but
anyway um have I ever watched the show
Lost yes I used to watch lost god I used
to watch lost all the time um I was
trying to understand of it like I hold
on it's like I'm listening to mark
appliers
draw my life like I want to do my man my
next Rob explains youtubers and yes I
know my apartments a wreck I need to
clean it up tonight probably you know I
probably will but um anyway I wanted I
want one next Rob explains youtubers to
be a video on on markiplier and so I
going through is draw my life and trying
to get as much info as I can and you
know publicly available stuff and just
kind of go from there
so let's see
let's listen to some tunes actually
let's listen to and tuna beats vol 6 and
junuh beats vol 6
preview like I love the preview I came
out years ago but it's so fun to listen
to you were looking forward on Rob
explained so I haven't uploaded it yet
but I'm like I said I'm probably gonna
try to have it out sometime in the next
several days or so but but yeah like I
want to I want to do a video markiplier
so I'm trying to get as much info as I
can but anyway so back to your question
um do i watch lost yes I used to watch
lost all the time like I was religiously
into it and I tried to understand it and
I tried to make sense of it and it was
just really difficult to do and so after
a while I was just kind of like I'll
just watch it for what it would be and
then just like when it ended I was like
well that's name and then just kind of
stopped after that so but I can see why
people lost interest in the show after a
while it seems like it just kind of went
on for too long
let's see uh have I played the taken
King raid yet no I haven't played the
taken King way I'm not high enough
like I haven't played destiny for a
couple of weeks just because I haven't
had enough time I've been like wildly
busy making videos like it's as soon as
I finished one script like I'm
immediately starting on the next like I
I have like no time to breathe like the
trip we took to Baltimore was like the
like the only real break I've had from
making videos for like months so yeah
like it's it's nuts am I gonna play
fallout 4 hopefully hopefully I have
chance to hopefully I have times let's
see have you heard of Rory he's like a
singer rapper now I haven't heard of
Rory before I assume it's how you
pronounce it like Maury with an honour
no I haven't heard of him
what do you think of edges of shield now
the first season was trashed second
season got a little more interesting and
now I think the third season started out
strong well I wouldn't say the first
season was trashed but I'd say it had it
had its weaknesses there were aspects of
it that weren't like that incredible
I would say that with the first season
it was it was trying to figure itself
out you know it was trying to get things
sorted out it was trying to understand
where it stood I guess is the best way
to put it you know but in terms of the
second season you know it was picking up
it was getting good and I think
introducing the Inhumans in the TV show
was a really good idea that was a much
better idea than simply just like just
yeah I'm life I think was a much better
idea there's someone just like throwing
things out there and kind of hoping for
the best but I think that you know it
was it was a really smart idea to to
fold them in that way and the way
they're doing it is really cool like
right now with season three it's
basically like like any human like the
Inhumans storyline by Charles Soule and
in humanity it's basically what that is
you know which is really really weird
because I would say that you know if
they're going with inhuman assuming
they're following the comic book a
storyline the coming book the
publication's the inhuman royal families
already collapsed and so my thought is
when the Inhumans movie comes out either
I mean they it looks like it's it's the
text of the film like the test the text
of their advertisement was the volume to
text and so like the the text you would
see on a human's volume too and so my
thought is that you know basically the
movies gonna serve as like a prequel of
sorts to to everything that's going on
with the Inhumans right now I could be
wrong but I'm kind of thinking that
might be the case and if it is then
that's really cool because then we'll
good to see Black Bolt Medusa all those
folks and see how that goes on but
nonetheless I think that what the Wayne
agents of shield is going right now is
it's actually pretty solid like I think
it's pretty cool um a huge fan from
Saudi Arabia started reading comics
religiously because of you so thanks
well you're welcome and I'm glad that my
channel this helps you out I appreciate
it like I'm glad of you you get a kick
out of it man my videos are helping you
through some really tough times thank
you so much Wong lat
like my videos are able to help you out
and to to get you in a better in a
better place so I am the advisor to the
comic book club at the high school where
I teach I'm going to start showing one
of your videos every week every time we
have a meeting well that's cool that's
pretty cool I appreciate that like I
think it's a really good idea
um any opinions on the x-men getting
screwed over post Secret Wars well I
don't really think they're getting
screwed over
it's just Marvel's like you know lead
they're trying to make the Inhumans
under the x-men and that's not gonna
happen like the Inhumans are never gonna
become that popular they're just the
x-men have too much history they've got
too many great stories you know the
Inhumans for all intensive purposes are
the new kids on the block granted
they've been around for a long time but
they've always been playing second
fiddle they've always been in the
background they've been shuffled around
and kind of thrown back there and
Marvel's just now trying to make them
popular and fans see that fans look at
what Marvel's doing with the Inhumans
right now and they say well the only
reason why the Inhumans matter is
because you can't get the rights to the
x-men it's not organic you know fans
know what Marvel's trying to do and they
don't like it you know they like you
know the x-men they like the idea of the
x-men and so on and so forth and so
that's why the x-men are sticking around
just because whenever movie comes out
from Fox
like you know they're gonna be able to
make make money on the comics so um how
do you think Secret Wars will end well
if they keep going with the current
trend right now it's never gonna end
it's a push back and so I have no idea I
don't have I don't know at this point I
have no clue I don't know
Rob I just sort of the channel focus on
comic books any suggestions for someone
starting out stick to stories that you
love make videos about stuff that you
love and and look at what I'm doing look
at what comics torian's doing look at
what Sal's doing what you know nerd
Singh is doing varying comics is doing
and find a way to do it better because
there's always ways to make better
videos and what we're doing there's
always ways to improve you know and
that's basically what you got to do you
know if you're making a channel about
comic books or any kind of a YouTube
channel you basically marketing yourself
and you got to say this is why you
should be watching my channel instead of
those guys or in addition to those guys
you know here's why my channels just as
good if not better and so I'd say go
with that approach pretty tame chatter
is it just me well it's just kind of
like a spur-of-the-moment thing like
like I said you don't normally I give
people you know two or three hours
though so by the time I started to thing
there's like a hundred seven people and
you're already and so it's slowly
building up hopefully it gets big but
also like like it's 250 in the afternoon
so I imagine a lot of kids are still in
school which by the way why don't you
guys in school there's my question but
any opinions on Mary Jane being in the
Iron Man comics because in my opinion I
don't like this idea and not one bit
well why don't you like the idea is my
question
I don't mind Mary Jane Watson being in
the Iron Man comics I mean it makes
sense they got to put her somewhere
so am I gonna cover legion probably for
the beyond omega-level mutant yeah most
likely because he's got hundreds of
personalities each personality having a
power now some of the powers are
duplicates not every power is different
but he has hundreds of powers basically
and he can control those powers so it's
pretty nuts all the stuff that he can do
let's see throw me a bone and touch on
the micronauts I'm we're not gonna touch
on the micro nuts do you think Moon
Knight will ever get a movie or a show
that's a good one
he might at some point along the line I
have no idea I personally wouldn't
invest in a moon night show I think it'd
be kind of interesting but I think the
problem with with Moon Knight is you
know a lot of people look at it and they
see him as like a spin on you know I
don't know they they see him as like a
spin on Batman which is basically what
he is like you know he is these Marvel's
Batman who's crazy who's got multiple
personality disorders so you know he's
nuts but I think that you know I think
the second bed got hit by a driver Wow
bad semester I hope you hope you get
better but no I mean he's he's
interesting enough on his own you know I
just you know he's one of those
characters that unless you're a hardcore
reader you don't know who he is so uh
Hulu is finally getting rid of
commercials about Tom yeah like I paid
like I'm paying about 12 bucks a month
now and they get rid of commercials you
know and it's like thank you Hulu like
what took you so long
you know like everybody else that has a
streaming services on that commercial so
why are you just now getting to that but
you know whatever the reason why I don't
like the idea of Mary Jane being an Iron
Man comic was because I thought renew
your vows was going to give us back to
marriage alive and kicking post secret
warriors well she doesn't really that's
the best kind of the funny thing the Dan
Slott said that when he made renew your
vows when he wrote the story that it was
written in a way to where you
could continue those elements passed
secret Wars but the story was basically
a nod to saying here's what things would
have looked like if one more day hadn't
happened like here's here's one's one
kind of story you would have seen you
know if he was allowed to write you know
something that could basically retcon
one more day that's effectively all it
was you know it will you know think of
it like a what-if story you know it
wasn't necessarily in Canon it wasn't
necessarily as though here's exactly how
things are gonna be it's just here's an
option and if mama wants to continue
with it they can and if they don't they
don't have to but given the popularity
of one where I'm sorry of renew your
vows you know given the fact that it was
consistently one of the highest selling
comics of Marvel had during Secret Wars
I would argue that we knew your vows is
gonna be extremely popular like it's
gonna be a big deal you know once Secret
Wars ends and we'll probably get some
variation of that I'm not really sure
injustice gods among us is the best kind
of book ever I've heard that like I've
really really heard that I want to get
into it you know I'm just trying to find
a good place to start you know because I
don't want to start it like year one
like I want to start all the way from
your one but you know I guess I might
have to in order to make it all make
sense but we'll see what's on by the way
thanks for explained feel not so lost in
comics now I appreciate it I'm glad I'm
glad it helps you out that's kind of the
kicker you know is is what the character
explanation is like I kind of exhausted
like all the characters that are being
talked about right now or although all
the main characters and I was trying to
find more interesting ways of doing
things and that's that was the whole
idea behind beyond omega-level because
I'll go ahead and throw it out there
like like Benny was like hey man like
I'm thinking about doing a video on
omega-level mutant it's like listen them
all like who's this guy Matthew Malloy
and I was like I don't know and so I
looked him up and we found out who he
was I was like you know what Benny I'm
jacking your idea and I'm gonna do a
video on beyond omega-level characters
and I did and it did well so um let's
see
uh hey huge fan I have a softball for
you I'm really trying to get it getting
into Batman comics and what lines do I
need to read for his new 52 line okay
well I mean all my video all my channels
pretty much caught up to date with
Batman right now you can watch my videos
if you want to if you don't want to you
can always go and you can always go when
you can look at
the individual trades which is what I
would suggest getting if you want to get
current with that man
the first one is quarter the owls and
court of the owls is really just like an
amalgamation of quarter the owls at
night of the owls it's a combination of
both they're basically like one on
wedding story after court of the house
and out of the annals comes death of the
family there's there's two different
ones there's two death in the family
which is the 1980s to the death of Jason
Todd that's not the one you want the one
you want is death of the family
and that's the one where the Joker makes
his return to the DC landscape in the
new 52 at least as a main villain of
Batman and the and the bat family in
terms of like his appearance in a major
story arc following that is Batman in
game and that's one we just finished
which which I won't I won't really spoil
that for you but yeah so my favorite
comic book character definitely this
century Robert Reynolds like I love this
entry model Reynolds he's a great
character say my name please
Abdul Sethi on me I think it's how you
say it
hopefully Rob regarding agents of shield
what do you think Simmons was taken by
the rock well my my personal opinion is
that she was taken to to the Kree
homeworld of hala
now here's the reason why in Marvel
Comics there was a story called
Operation galactic storm and at one
point in the history of the Kree Empire
they were this wildly technological you
know this technologically advanced race
they were super advanced and they were
capable of all these things and all that
kind of stuff but the problem was there
was a stone called the forever crystal
and we covered this in my video about
the Kree there was a stone called the
forever crystal and one of the Kree
members of the Kree society or something
like that came along came along that
that artifact they touched it or
something like that and like it froze
their their evolution in place they
didn't evolve anymore they basically
were stuck where they were at and so
their spiritual their spiritual guide
the amalgamation of all the intelligence
that exists within the realm of the Kree
Empire called the supreme intelligence
made the decision to basically instigate
a war
and you know within the universe and so
the whole operation galactic storm
things saw that and it was basically
done as a way to jumpstart the evolution
of the Cree and so like like 90% of the
Cree race was wiped out completely
annihilated and what was left where this
where it was this race called the rule
which was they look like predators
basically it's exactly where they look
like they look like predators and so
with most of the rates gone it leaves a
perfect opportunity open for Marvel to
come along with agents of shield and say
well she's on hala but like you know the
whole operation galactic storm already
happened and the courier virtually wiped
out there's like 10% of them left you
know and so they've kind of fallen into
decay or any number of things like that
you know but but I think that's that's
kind of what they might be going with I
could be wrong but that's my argument
for why she's on the planet holler so
steve buscemi from at jim Jasper's in
the MCU that's not gonna happen let's
see what do you think of it okay we
always like but ages of fuel season 3
yeah I think it's coming along pretty
well so far so do you think Marvel has
hurt themselves with all these delays
and Secret Wars hard to follow with such
long boy it really is and that's that's
why you know I'm I'm going with the idea
of target of going over the stories as
they come out you know because basically
you know once Secret Wars completes
people could just go through all my
videos and bam they're right there they
can go through them in succession and
they don't have to really worry about it
you know they can they can say okay you
know what like I'm gonna I'm gonna buy
the stories I'm gonna read it you know
we either imagine they come out but once
they finish the whole series you know if
a reason some reason I forgot some fact
or they're not really sure that kind of
you know for getting things new the
amount of Taunus this that's that has
taken they can always just go to my
channel and you know come to my channel
they can go over everything you have the
sexiest manly voice it's my voice really
that great guys like that's what I want
to know like like I mean you know I
don't I don't think it's that great
people tell me that but like I hate the
sound of my voice the most ridiculous
coming of a character
huh the most ridiculous chemical
character I don't know I mean there's
some dumb comic book characters in terms
of like Marvel Comics I think one of the
more ridiculous Kevin book characters
are probably super scroll which is like
a scroll that has the powers of the
Fantastic Four you know in terms of DC
Comics I don't know enough about all
their characters to really make that
argument but I would say your voice is
amazeballs I'll take your word for it
you know in terms of mm in terms of the
characters that I dunno I think cyborg
is a pretty useless character but I know
there's gonna be hardcore sidework fans
who were like yeah don't even say
something like who's behind me nobody's
behind me not that I know of so what do
you think would happen
who wouldn't oh who do you think would
win Superman versus the whole well
that's been done to death but I would
say that I don't know I would say the
probably the Hulk would win because I
think that the Superman's strength stops
at a point but the hoax doesn't it's
just he gets infinitely angrier but you
know having said that that's assuming
that he need to step and step up and
take over voice overs once Morgan
Freeman's gone I don't know about taking
over voiceover once Morgan Freeman's
gone Morgan Freeman's here replaceable
anyway so with regards to the Superman
fighting the Incredible Hulk the problem
is that with Superman or I'm sorry with
the Incredible Hulk you know Superman is
so powerful he probably able to kill the
Incredible Hulk like right off the bat
and so you're in my bed that's kind of
creepy but I think that he I think that
Superman would kill the Incredible Hulk
right off the bat before he got angry
enough to become unstoppable but I don't
know so captain carrot Bucky O'Hare if
you can't remember Bucky O'Hare from
back in the day like we saw what was it
we saw him somebody saw I think it was
Sal me and him were hanging out and he
saw Bucky O'Hare and
Baltimore Comic Con and he was like oh
my god you know like like oh there's
nobody on my bed right now like it's
just me like it's just me I'm like that
or just me here in my apartment it
doesn't mean there won't be somebody on
my bed later on but it's just me right
now
oh I haven't read the latest justice CGI
justice league yet although I need to am
i Batman no well I could another confirm
nor deny Batman I will say this though I
can't I'm not saying that I'm not Batman
I'm just saying that no one's ever seen
me in Batman in the same room so let's
see the biggest problem is that hole
can't fly so if Superman gets him in
space it's over uh yeah I probably you
just crush him Robert Freeman I think it
I think if it's no I could never replace
Morgan Freeman that guy's voice is
golden like Morgan Freeman's voices man
I could listen to that do you talk
forever like he's got an amazing voice
let's see should Bruce Timm create an
animated Marvel you oh I'd watch it how
he had watch it like I'd be down with
that do you keep up with DBZ or Dragon
Ball super yes let's see
like any Marvel games I try to play a
few more games but um I can't rift Bucky
O'Hare Rizzo Neal Adams creation or not
but anyway I tried to play a few Marvel
games but I really couldn't get into it
like Marvel heroes stuff like that like
I really couldn't get into it
do you believe heroes should be able to
alter and adapt coming book characters
as much as it's done from coming to
comic Oh believe movies should be able
to alter in adapt now because it would
destroy sense of consistency and that's
the problem like that's one of the
things we're gonna find when we go over
my definitive Superman video and or I
guess when when you guys whenever at
least my definitive Superman video
because the next definitive Superman
video is gonna focus on his powers over
the years like that's not what's gonna
be like this one will be powers the next
one will be kryptonite probably the one
after that will be you know the various
members of the Superman family and so on
but one thing we'll notice is that he
had an initial power set which is pretty
basic because it was a reflection of
poll comics at the time they had to be
powers that made him interesting but
they couldn't be so far removed from
what fans were used to that it seemed
ridiculous and so the idea was you know
as time progressed and when we got into
the late 1940s and we got to the
1950s oh my singer took over the title
his powers became more and more
ridiculous to the point that by the time
crisis on Infinite Earths came around
you know he was like a godly character
like he could do ridiculous things and
so they had to just be like we got to
wipe this dude clean like we gotta we
had to do something because he's godly
powerful and it's nuts you know if that
was movies you know and you had like the
Man of Steel and then you have you know
Batman vs Superman the dawn of Justice
and then you have another Superman movie
and then so like four or five Superman
movies down the law and he's pulling a
chain of planets out of a universe or
out of a galaxy
people just gonna be like Ryan even for
a Superman movie this is ridiculous you
know and they're gonna throw their hands
up in the air and walk away and so you
can get away with a lot more you believe
James Earl Jones as king avoid oh no
James all drones yeah he's got a pretty
pretty good voice those guys are on a
whole nother echelon from me so but I
think that you can get a lot of get away
with a lot more in comics and you can in
movies and so you know let's see have
you read deadly class no I have a read
deadly class ah let's see
you love Dragon Ball Z it's awesome I do
love Dragon Ball Z like I love it a lot
like I think it's pretty solid why
wasn't the x-men part of the Infinity
Gauntlet story like Cyclops was but that
was really it the goal of the Infinity
Gauntlet story when it was written as
far as I understand it from from jim
Starlin you think I'd remember a name
like that his goal was to basically take
like the most popular characters and
incorporate them in they at the time the
Incredible Hulk
Cyclops of x-factor you know those those
guys were the most popular characters
Marvel had and so the idea was to bring
them into the Infinity Gauntlet story
and have them fighting there's a way to
draw fans in I mean honestly would you
really read an Infinity Gauntlet story
if you had you know like I don't know
squirrel girl fighting fan okay well I
would read Infinity Gauntlet story that
had squirrel girl fighting Thanos but
like somebody had somebody done you know
like an archangel would you really read
a story about angel fighting thing I was
like I wouldn't because it seemed
ridiculous you do I get down I doesn't
have a chance you know but but
nonetheless the Secret Wars matter yes
Secret Wars does matter okay okay guys
so think about it this way because we've
talked about this before in previous
videos and so on and so forth Secret
Wars works like
this alright we'll use the we use the
tip of my e-cig to answer this question
Darwin versus fury The Fury definitely
okay so think of it like this alright
the you've got the Marvel Universe
alright this great big huge expansive
Marvel continuity and let's say that
this napkin represents the Marvel
Universe alright this right here this
tip of my East thing right here is
Secret Wars alright what's happening is
you've got this great big huge universe
that's being sent through this thing if
I can get this damn thing to work right
okay you've got this universe going
through here and Marvel is literally
just pulling out what they want to keep
on the other side
that's basically what Secret Wars is
it's a giant what if story it's then
funneling out all the crap they don't
want the problem is the Secret Wars is
taking so damn long to come out that
fans are just like just in the damn
thing already house but else that's kind
of where they're at you know at the
moment and and it makes sense you know
to a degree it makes sense that that's
how fans are reacting to it so what
direction do you want post Secret Wars
for spider-man
I want Miles Morales to be the main
spider-man I want win Stacey to go back
to her own universe which is what's
happening and I want Peter Parker to
take a backseat for once like Peter
Parker's been spider-man for years for
like 70 or 60 years something like that
you know 60 some odd years would be some
odd years whatever he's been in
spider-man for a long time it's time to
let Peter Parker go and it's time to let
Miles Morales take his place you know I
think we're I think that's high time you
know and so I want to see that happen I
know that that miles when Ellis is
getting his own solo series but I know
Peter Parker is gonna get his own solo
series too so yeah you know I'm kind of
curious to see how all that goes let's
see an all of Marvel who has the most
incredible mind was a toss-up is it
toss-up between three people there is
the napkin verse yes the napkin verse is
what this is it's the napkin verse it's
a universe made of napkins you know I
think that first one in 2016
what was the question I forgot what the
question whether they asked no well
that's your question again because I
forgot what you asked what on earth can
be blackballed considering he goes toe
to toe with gladiator and killed Vulcan
well Blackpool's powers been reduced
over the years you know they were
reduced as a result of infinity as a
result of that you know the inhumanities
story and all that kind of stuff so he's
not nearly as as strong as he used to be
you know but he is still a pretty solid
character having said that I mean you
could literally just like shoot Black
Bolt you could have a guy perched up on
a building a mile away
who's accurate enough and he could like
shoot Black Bolt through the head with a
gun and black boat would be dead you can
do that so it's not impossible to kill
black bull you know things like that
earth to zero robbers oh you were
talking about the smartest people um
yeah yeah so that I was trying to think
of what it was that you were asking yeah
so the three so one is like it's really
like three people you've got you've got
free I'm sorry you got Reed Richards and
you've got Doctor Doom who usually like
change positions based on the writer
sometimes Reed Richards a smaller
sometimes dr. doom is smarter but you
know usually it depends on the on who's
writing the story at the time but for
the most part you know those two switch
places so they're like number one you
know considered the two of them number
one number two usually you know I would
say that probably comes around to be
like valeri Richards and she might even
be a contender for number one there's
because she's so astronomically smarter
there have been stories especially in
and Jonathan Hickman's run of the whole
time runs out thing you know Jonathan
Hickman writing the Future Foundation
and so on where she's right up there
with Reed Richards and dr. doom black
panther is considered in the top five
and then so I'd probably put him at like
number two officially assuming that we
jumble up and we mix up Valyria doom and
Reid and then for number three you know
I'd probably throw out Amadeus Cho you
know he's super smart so you know it's
somewhere around there let's see Thanos
Thanos and Darkseid versus Hulk and
doomsday who would win
Thanos in Darkseid yeah there's no
contest they're like they would destroy
Vulcan doomsday a better question would
be
Thanos and Hulk vs. the
doomsday that would be a better argument
in which case I'd say it'd probably be
dark Sun and doomsday um let's see you
uh are you watching and enjoy Dragon
Ball super definitely like I'm really
enjoying Dragon Ball super um let's see
I am skirt steak taco man I'll take your
word for it
what's your opinion on the ultimate
universe as a whole do you think it
should and or not well it is like the
ultimate universe is gone like it's not
an existence anymore the none of that
stuff is in existence anymore like Oh
banner is really smart he's just like
not not up there with anybody with like
all the other people when you get to
Bruce Banner you're getting down to you
know like 6th 7th 8th smartest people
which like once you cross that threshold
I'd like to top 10 the smartest people
in Marvel it's really just arbitrary in
terms of where you to find people you
know I know where I you know until you
get to like the top 3 or something like
that like like 4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10 or
just kind of whoever you want them to be
it's really just you know it really just
kind of depends let's see what happened
to your Walking Dead comic TV show with
so it's a weekly series so it comes up
once a week you know let's see wait uh
so there are still the same characters
just labeled as Inhumans yeah I mean
that's that's all it is like I mean odd
I assume you're talking about Secret
Wars just to make sure we're clarifying
here like clarify let me know if you're
talking about Secret Wars or like agents
of shield because that's kind of like
out in the blue um favorite part of
Infinity Gauntlet when Thanos wipes out
half the life in the universe like hands
down you know when he snaps his fingers
and wipes out half the life in the
universe is my favorite moment let's see
do you read Gotham by midnight no I
haven't read that yet I heard it's
pretty good but I haven't read that yet
what's your opinion on the new 52
there's a great starting point for DC
fans you know that's how I got into DC
with new 52 you know I was on the fence
and then I was talking a billion sound
they well I just read new 52 I don't
worry about the old stuff unless you're
talking about Green Lantern and even
then you don't really need to you can
just start with like you know reimagine
rebirth and go from there so
you know um let's see what's your
favorite part I'll already answer that
is Johnny storm really the Sun in
Ultimate Comics what uh no it's not
alternate comics at Secret Wars and yeah
he's that he's the son as far as I know
like they said that like that doom was
like he's the son now like he sits out
in the sky and likes the planet
shouldn't the female Thor be called Odin
daughter
Odin daughter instead of Odin son and
what if Thor had some had a son would he
be called Odin grandson I don't know I
don't know how that works
I mean it's surnames so it wouldn't be
Odin grandson like if there were had a
son he would be it would be like Thor
son it would be like some guy Thor son
in terms of the female Thor were like
she's not Odin daughter she's just
thought they just call her that you know
like like Thor was called Odin son
because he was the son of Odin you know
it goes into that north mythology and
surnames and so on so Justice League 44
the new flow there's a new flash in
Justice League 44 like I need to check
that out what mod is this this is the
sigelei a 100-watt plus best portrayal
of magneto and comics definitely greg
packs magneto testament if you have not
read greg packs Magneto's testament you
are seriously missing out like magneto
testament is an unbelievable story it's
probably one of the best stories that
you're ever gonna read about magneto
because it's quite literally the rise of
his character you know
let's see my favorite part is when the
Silver Surfer makes a dash for the
gauntlet yeah it was really really cool
like like Adam warlock was like go now
which would be something really cool to
see you know something to that capacity
Johnny and Johnny Storm is a Johnny
Storm as a son now yeah like we went
over that in my
um let's see which by the way if you
guys are ever curious about whether or
not I have a video on something you guys
can always search my channel there's a
there's a search bar there you know
that'll let you look up any videos that
I have in case you know you don't feel
like sorting through everything so it's
Franklin Richard stronger than the
Infinity Gauntlet um yeah well now I
wouldn't say stronger than the Infinity
Gauntlet because he's not on par with
like eternity but you know the Infinity
gun was able to control eternity to
manipulate eternity Franklin Richards is
like he's he'd be equivalent like the
Infinity stone of the of the Infinity
Gauntlet like that that would be the
equivalent of Franklin Richards would be
like the Infinity stone let's see what
do I get to get into Marvel I don't
really know much about it Reed Avengers
vol 3 actually don't even do that just
read like just just start with Secret
Wars
just breathe [ __ ] Wars is really all
you need question what is your opinion
of convergence as a whole well until
they actually this convergence man
convergence was it was about it didn't
sell well like it did terrible like like
how many book companies were just like
we're dying trying to sell like this
thing no one's buying it all Convergys
was was DC coming back and saying okay
yes we know that we rebooted the
continuity with a new 52 but like all
the pre new 52 realities are there if
you're interested in reading those like
those work and those are official like
those exist and they haven't done
anything with them yet they're just
there you know and and that's it you
know so let's see
how do I feel about Sansa playing Jean
Grae I don't mind it's fine with me
or just watch all the videos cuz you're
badass let's see well the original
beholder ever comes out you talk about
the Beyonder I think it's what you're
talking about
let's see how powerful do you consider
Scarlet Witch personally I think she's
the most powerful of injury oh she's
definitely the most powerful of injury I
mean she's really powerful in terms of
like mutants and stuff you know I mean
she worked reality so I mean she created
the House of M universe so you know and
it wasn't really that like in see here's
a problem like she didn't really work
reality per se and she made a new
reality and sent people there is what
she did like that's what the the house
of a house forum universe was it was a
whole new continuity um let's see what
is your opinion of spider-man one moment
in time it was a terrible it was a
terrible follow up to a story they got a
lot of controversy is what I'll say
because I don't think one more day was
badly written I think was a beautifully
written story the reason behind it was
bad but you know one more than time was
terrible decision they should've just
left it alone let's see okay here's
here's not one one moment on felt one
moment in time felt like you know Marvel
like Joker thought it was like all right
guys we're rebooting to be and we're
getting rid of the whole spider-man
thing like we're getting rid of the
mayors of one on yards of fans were like
why would you do this and then one
moment in time was like well here like
here's what we're doing that like let me
make it make sense like fans didn't want
it to make sense I just didn't want it
to happen so that's all that was how
long have you been into comics for years
let's see what up Rob I just finished
reading death of the family and I was
wondering if you would recommend reading
0 year which I'm going straight into
endgame ah you can jump straight into
endgame 0 years not necessary I mean if
you want the story of how Batman became
or how Bruce Wayne became Batman 0 years
for you but you know you don't
necessarily need to that's really all
you need so that's another common
question can you explain Batman and
spawn I can't find it and do you like
the story I haven't read it so
I really couldn't I don't know what was
your reaction to the photos of Peter
Parker of David Tennant as purple might
not Jessica Jones I was psyched like I'm
one I'm just glad to bring in the purple
man because it means that they're not
gonna be screwing around they're gonna
be creating some pretty hardcore stuff
so I'm pretty psyched but yeah like I'm
really happy to see the purple man you
know and as far as I know from what
Brian Michael Bendis said like it's
going to be dark like it's going to be
very dark and so I'm really excited to
see how that turns out if all the
universe is destroyed as Secret Wars why
does the MCU still exist because reasons
but because supposedly the MCU and the
Marvel Comics universe are totally
separate and they don't affect one
another which is evident and the fact
that we're seeing the inhumanity event
play out in you know the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and ages of shield
but you know nothing to see here folks
move along do you think which civil
whatever returned in the MCU no he's
dead
he was shot to pieces so he's gone what
is your thoughts on the New Avengers
Jane Foster
Thor so on in the comics and how that
will affect how that will affect the the
Cinematic Universe well that's that's
gonna be the kicker isn't it I mean
they're you know I think they're trying
to I think they're launching this as a
way to kind of try to establish that
things are totally different at the MCU
and the comics are completely different
entities I don't know I think that it
won't really have an effect on the MCU
or it may it's really difficult to tell
right now I would say that if the MCU is
going to follow track with the comics
that will become evident after infinity
war when infinity war ends probably
gonna be a lot of resetting there's
gonna be some reality warping there's
gonna be a lot of redoing and
reintroductions and so on and so forth
and that I think is when we will see
whether or not they will actually match
before right now you know it's hard to
know like it's I don't know it's hard to
tell if the only way all different
Avengers will affect the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so what is your
opinion on the Metal Gear Solid series
as a whole oh I love Metal Gear I've
been playing Metal Gear since Metal Gear
Solid 1 on the PlayStation so I haven't
played the new one yet
I'm a played the current metal
you're solid like like Tzadik ol candy
was giving me like a really hard time we
were in Baltimore like she was giving me
a bunch of flack for having not seen it
you know or have not played it she was
like what's wrong with you you know
which which by the way like sonic was
really really cool so she's really fun
to hang out with like Benny Benny and
Zanna cool like they're they're really
cool to chill with is my Panther the
richest superhero in comic books as the
cello has an entire kingdom yes see this
fortune is well not in comic books as a
whole in Marvel Comics yes his fortune
is massive just because he owns a single
source of vibranium in the whole world
so these were rich let's see hey Rob
being a fan of video games have you ever
read ready player one if so do you agree
Tom Cavanagh no I haven't played I
haven't haven't heard of that or
anything so let's see do you what do you
predict will happen to the at the end of
seeker war I think dooms gonna die and I
think the end of the energy they
beyonders like their power is gonna be
used to create a create a multiverse
let's see what do you think of Missy and
I joining the MCU I think it's a cool
idea I mean again it goes to words like
the ground level you know hero stuff it
goes towards the ground level things you
know and so on you know the the the
Daredevils of the world and you know
Luke Cage and Jessica Jones you know and
that kind of thing it goes towards
grounded superheroes that fight on the
street level because misty Knight was
part of Heroes for Hire so that's that's
really where she got her big thing from
let's see what will you do when you
finally get to four in a thousand subs I
keep making videos shut it all down
end it all no way do you think DC can
catch up to Marvel when it comes to
movies and TV shows
answer please fYI guys tacking on the
tagging on like please read this or
answer please do something like that
does not determine whether or not your
answer gets read I just read the
questions or doesn't doesn't run what
about your question gets read I read the
questions that I find the most
intriguing so or the ones that that I
have time to read because somebody of
them come in I would say that with them
with
with DC it's literally it's best not to
compare them you know DC's got great TV
shows I mean models TV shows I mean
really good you got daredevil which is
really the only really good TV show they
have they got it as a shield which is
getting better but you know seasons 1 &
2 were pretty weak the Obon DC's got you
know the flash they've got arrow you
know Gotham I really couldn't even do
that I stopped watching it but do you
see I don't really think it's like you
know ketchup per se you know I think
DC's
cranked it along and doing fine in their
own universe so I think their shows are
pretty solid you know one able to able
to stand on their own pretty well let's
see what are your thoughts on the lack
of secret identities in the MCU I think
it makes the heroes more realistic you
know I think it makes them more
reasonable you know I mean brand the
idea that daredevil has a secret
identity nobody knows that Matt Murdock
as daredevil except for a handful of
people you know of course those closest
friends and and so on you know but I
think that you know if secret identities
are like an archaic thing you know
there's something from way back when
that used to be really relevant but not
relevant so much anymore any negative
thoughts on Jessica Jones now I hold off
on on you know judgment until I watch
the series so let's see did you ever
read the comics the comics are books for
a dark tower um I assume you're talking
about Stephen King stark tower like I
read some of those you know why was the
tribunal so easily killed by the by the
beyonders because they possess an
extreme amount of power I guess I'm not
sure and something that was just done
really explained it's just that they
have an extraordinary amount of our and
that's how they did it it's it's really
kind of weird you know when you get into
that territory but let's see uh have I
read the big have I read the Big Trouble
in Little China I didn't know they had
Big Trouble in Little China comics but
lo pan is amazing everything's better
with Lohan let's see
Rob what games have you most recently
played um I played Skyrim last night and
that's about it I played that for a
couple hours and got back to working on
videos so that's the kicker guys like
like I know a lot of you guys are just
like man like it must be really bug you
know it's really really cool to be a
youtuber and like you go hang out and
like go on trips and party all the time
and all that kind of stuff we go to
comic book conventions like you're in
comics during cons season for like three
months we go to coming book conventions
for the rest of the year we're working
on videos all the time like non-stop
working on videos so I don't have time
to play games I gotta really have time
to do anything besides make videos so
let's see what nineties character work
comic is my guilty pleasure um in Skyrim
I'm a Nord I don't really have like a
guilty pleasure comic I mean now I don't
really have guilty pleasure comics so
let's see what is your favorite color
Oh my favorite color green I love green
any thoughts on how ghost riders should
contribute to the MCU if you were to be
brought in um I don't really have any
thoughts on that because I don't think
that Ghost Rider should be brought into
the MCU you're going to New York
comic-con will you see me no I'm
actually gonna be a wedding so I'm not
gonna be able to make it this year which
sucks because I really wanted to go but
can you do a video on valuing comics yes
I'll definitely be doing a video on
value comics I will be doing a video
about that how much pretty soon yeah so
most likely you know because the whole
like the Thursday like the day when the
The Walking Dead videos come out that's
the indie comic day and so once the
Walking Dead and is like once I finished
that I'll probably switch over and start
doing some characters from Valiant
Comics let's see
do I think Franklin winters will play a
big part post Secret Wars um I think so
but again like it's really hard to know
like it's really really difficult to
tell because Hickman with Hickman is a
guessing game honestly in terms of
characters Hickman could kill off
anybody at any point in time it's like
the game of Thrones and so we I have no
idea this is these are AKG headphones
these are studio headphones um let's see
who is spawn go watch my video and
you'll find out oh my gosh so many
questions rolling in let's see what are
your thoughts about flash season 2 I'm
really hyped for the different versions
like for Jay Garrick like I'm pretty
psyched about him well we got a video on
Jay Garrick so you know make sure you
guys check that out but aside from that
like I'm hope to see what kind of
versions they come up with and so on
like I'm I'm pretty interested um let's
see what do you think happened to the
Hulk after age of Ultron he just went
into hiding probably on earth somewhere
and doesn't care anything about what
anybody's doing like I think what's
happening right now is the equivalent of
Planet Hulk is him like out you know on
earth you know completely isolated from
the events of civil war at least that's
what makes sense to me let's see what
about flash season 2 and earth Q well
that's that's kind of one of things that
I'm hoping it'll officially say like
this is earth to like that's what I'm
really looking forward to and I mean
flash comes out next week so I'm really
looking I'm really interested to see
what they really should to see what they
say let's see you want to see me play
something on the guitar now I'm not
gonna play anything on the guitar
I don't watch talk to you I never got
into Doctor Who I know that's like a big
no-no people are just like oh my god
what like how could you be in geek
culture or not much talked a little bit
never really watched it let's see what
do you what do you mostly want out of
the Civil War movie
I want the death of Captain America I
want like a huge battle between like
multiple heroes and yeah that's pretty
much it I mean I think we'll see
everything else I mean I think we're
getting you know the whole philosophy
and a lot kind of stuff but the problem
is it's one movie you know so that it's
really gonna be like a fast-paced film
so it's gonna be hard it's gonna be hard
to really get like the an
all-encompassing feel of civil war
within that movie but I think it'll
still be pretty solid so thoughts on
Cumberbatch playing Doctor Strange you
know I think that you know all right so
so cucumber member patches like he's a
solid actor in my personal opinion I
think that like Adrienne Gillan probably
would have been a better you know Doctor
Strange but you know I think that you
know that that Bill patch will be he'll
do a pretty good job so you know I don't
think that he'll be terrible you know
it'll be interesting because he's you
know again he's pretty solid he played
Doctor Who for a while so I'm interested
to see where Sherlock Holmes rather so
I'm interested to see where he goes with
it but I think he'll do a pretty good
job yeah but see do uh what do you think
of Dark Side Wars um it's pretty good
it's pretty interesting so far um it's
not the most entertaining thing that
I've read but it's pretty interesting
you know let's see how long before saw
Bruce Wayne suits back up that's my
question you know and that's gonna be
the thing you know we will launch like
I'll do a video on you know Tim Gordon
Batman once Bruce Wayne puts the suit
back on because that'll officially be
like the end of Jim Gordon Batman's arc
but I'm not really sure you know I'm
kind of curious to see how it goes you
know but I don't I don't know you know
it's hard to know let's see do you think
print comics will be replaced by digital
comics no not at all because there's
just something about having a physical
comic in your hand you know that is this
something that people love you know
people love having a physical comic you
know in their hand if for no other
reason that perhaps it'll be like worth
a lot it's important um you know it's
it's difficult to know you know for
example I got the the Secret Wars one of
the one of the Secret Wars versions one
in 100 covers which means that for every
100 issues that
comic book store buys they get one
variant cover and I bought one of them
and and I really like the way it looks
and I'll probably never sell it you know
but I like having that you know that
physical copy in my possession which is
something that I had that I dig so let's
see thoughts on upcoming Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Batman crossover
I didn't know they were doing that but
I'm actually pretty hyped to see how
they go
favorite Batman story hmm probably hush
like hush is a really solid Batman story
one of my favorites so any opinions on
the pre new 52 Superman versus the new
52 Superman well I mean pretty new 52
you was clearly more powerful in terms
of everything that he can do and the
amount of strength that he has even
after the retcons for for you know not
85 you know crisis honor for the nurse
but no I'd say that yeah I'd say pre do
52 Superman and Plus pre new 52 super
and has that air of like an experienced
Superman like he's seen some stuff you
know like he's done some things like a
wise older person you know like like
three new v2 Superman feels like a 40
year old guy you know that's been around
the world and done things as opposed to
like the new 52 Superman who's like a 21
year old kid that thinks he knows how
the world works you know that's the
difference you know because there's no
21 year olds out there that know how the
world works so let's see any opinions on
Batman Beyond well as soon as I bring
back Terry McGinnis it'll be Batman
Beyond you know right now it's Tim Drake
I think and that's dick grayson whoever
it is like it's not it's not Terry
McGinnis oh it's not that man beyond so
I don't really care about it let's see
do you think Superman is boring now
here's the kicker when it comes to that
guy it's like the the boring nature of
characters or the interesting nature of
characters it's contextual based on the
story you know Superman's powers being
reduced and him basically being like you
know reverted back to his Golden Age
self with Superman truth is one of the
best Superman stories I've read and
long time you know where a Superman that
can pull planets not the most
interesting but you can take any
character and if you give them to a good
writer
don't be able to give you a compelling
story then be able to give you a really
good story you know and so it really
just it really just kind of depends you
know all-star Superman by Grant Morrison
is a perfect example
you know beautifully written story an
incredible story deals with a Lois Lane
it deals with Superman how he views
himself how he views himself in the eyes
of how Lois Lane views him you know it's
incredibly written you know
let's see best Batman movie probably
mask of the phantasm like greatest
Batman movie of all time Rob what's one
thing you did for geek and sundry what's
the thing you differ geek and sundry a
while ago you guys will find an audience
under each channel when they launched
the series um let's see hey Rob sir
possible as a been confirmed old man
Logan is coming back after battle world
I don't think it's been good no I think
it has been confirmed I think he's
coming back I think they're gonna
continue him which of course they would
because he was one of the one of the
best-selling stories they have for
secret war so it would make any sense to
drop that off they can keep making a ton
of money on that so let's see what about
what about this Superman vs Superman
outside of existence let's see keep
doing what you're doing Rob love the
vids well I appreciate it um question
why is Marvel making spider-man like
that man only they are I mean he's gonna
be a thing as a socialite but it doesn't
mean he's like Batman and you know think
so I mean if everybody who was wealthy
was like Batman then like Black Panthers
like that man
and spider-man's like black like Batman
and Reed Richards is like Batman and
Doctor Doom is like Batman like it's not
you can't use wealth as a way to decide
whether somebody's like Batman or not
Nolan or Burton Christopher Nolan
definitely Tim Burton admitted that he
never read Batman comics when he made
the movie and I doubt Christopher Nolan
did either but his movies are still
better so um let's see
Rob have you ever thought about
narrating for National Geographic wild
or animal planet I think it'd be cool
you know but I don't know how to how to
do that a second
put user in timeout there we go I get to
put people in timeout and that's fun
they get to go sit in the corner in your
opinion with Nicolas Cage make a good
doctor strange no no he would not he
would not make a good doctor strange
let's see I'm super stoked for Power
Rangers for the reboot yeah I'm actually
pretty interested to see what they do
um let's see will you ever ever what
black Batman yeah Oh black like Batman
okay black panther weather Oh Nolan said
he did read the comics okay I didn't I
didn't never I've never you know heard
whether or not he said that so you know
when this guy keeps asking about tacos
so this guy this guy gets banned that
guy's just getting annoying let's see
thoughts on heroes reborn I'm actually
pretty excited I think he's coming along
pretty good the first episode you know
is it's pretty good but you know no
you're not in time out it was some guy
asking ridiculous questions it's kind of
being a dick so I put him in timeout
I'm actually pretty hyped about heroes
reborn you know heroes are born I think
is gonna be he would love to listen to
me narrator National Geographic I don't
know how to do it like I don't have to
get into that I don't know how to get
into like narrating for companies like
that I think it'd be cool but I don't
know how to do that kind of thing
let's see anyway what was the u.s. oh
yeah so thoughts on heroes reborn
I'm actually really diggin it like I
think it's gonna be cool I'm glad
they're doing this with it yeah I know I
need to clean my apartment you know get
my place cleaned up I know that I'm glad
that they're doing it as a miniseries
and just kind of going from there I
think that it's a smart move because if
as the show continues on it Hanks
they're not out a whole bunch of money
they're basically not it's
like not a failed project you know it's
like well I mean it was only gonna be a
miniseries we didn't want to do anything
after that you know just wanted to keep
it there or they can just come out and
say like hey like we were interested to
see if there would be you know interest
in making more heroes episodes but you
know people didn't dig it so we just got
rid of it let's see after I read swords
how can I get in
Oh Secret Wars how can I get into Marvel
just by starting off like just read
Secret Wars and then just continue on
after that that's really all you need so
did you go to college yes um let's see
hey Rob have you been watching Dragon
Ball super yes will DC Marvel ever team
up in the movies I don't know but I wish
they would I think it'd be pretty solid
to see like a Marvel DC team up in the
films like I definitely watch the heck
out of that Rob will you cover injustice
gods among us I may have some point you
know I don't know how long have you done
this we've been doing this for about 40
minutes probably got about 10 more
minutes and then we're gonna call it a
day
let's see Scott Snyder or Frank Miller
Batman Scott Snyder Batman Frank Miller
is good man you know The Dark Knight
Returns is really good but scratch
matters Batman's incredible let's see
do you still check up on a weekly pulled
net oh yeah I second the notion of
robbed of the rob squad know it sister
ah poor let's see
well what have you done
Oh what have okay um I have no idea what
you were asking you've talked about this
before but do you still want to do it
did oh dude if deceit like if there was
a story called Deadpool kills the DC
Universe you know how fast that would
sell out like that would be nuts I would
but as far as I know there is no story
about Deadpool killing the DC Universe
otherwise like I would definitely check
that out like it'd be amazing let's see
who should take over the x-men movies
after Bryan Singer Marvel the Marvel
Marvel Studios title supposed to get
Wars that you're looking forward to ah
definitely a force old man Logan let's
see who else probably spider-man Miles
Morales and Peter Parker and the only
wall different adventures it's really
all really it like well those are really
the only ones that I'm looking forward
to you know after stick of war since
let's see have you heard anything about
the Justice League movie not really and
I mean nothing more than what you guys
have heard I'm sure
so daredevil in civil war probably see
him as someone will probably see some
daredevil you know or something like
that I mean it doesn't make any sense
that we wouldn't see you know any of
those guys doesn't make any sense we
wouldn't see Luke Cage we wouldn't see
Jessica Jones you wouldn't see daredevil
it doesn't make any sense that we
wouldn't see them so I'm pretty sure
we'll see those characters you know in
long lines and in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
let's see where at least I guess in
civil war itself questions coming faster
than while yeah it's really tough to
keep up with all these questions so
let's see the superheroes what superhero
or heroes would you like to see get a
Netflix show
huh
I don't know um you know wouldn't mind
seeing like a Green Lantern show on
Netflix I think we pretty solid and I
mean like Geoff Johns Green Lantern with
like all the lantern cores and all that
kind of stuff like that I think would be
pretty solid
let's see Rob will you be watching
arrows season for definitely definitely
Tom Hardy is Wolverine not really
filling Tom Hardy is Wolverine but I
could see Tom Hardy as a Punisher Jon
Bernthal will be a great Punisher you
know but I could definitely see like I
could definitely see you know Tom Hardy
as the Punisher how many more beyond
omega-level mutant psyche one or two
there really aren't that many mutants
that are beyond Omega level like there's
only a handful you know there's like mr.
M there is oh God
that's really about it
actually maybe like Legion if we
consider him you know we already did a
video on the Beyonder you know so it's
gonna be kinda you know we really can't
like redo that let's see will you be
making a Mandarin explaining video in
the near future not unless he becomes a
prominent character again which as far
as I know he's not I mean the Mandarin
hasn't been seen or mentioned a long
time so they wouldn't really make a lot
of sense to do a video on him right now
let's see any opinions on the DC
Animated universe in appears to Marvel
animation well I trying to compare the
two but you know DC Animated has some
amazing movies I'm all it is - I mean
like the Doctor Strange animated film is
really really good you know Avengers
Assemble was pretty good you know on the
DC side you've got the Dark Knight
Returns I think it was you've got a
bunch of really good you know animated
you know animated series coming in for
the DC Universe though
do I think the Nick Fury will survive
into secret Wars yeah definitely
let's see what happened to Bruce Banner
who who is a new whole kid Amadeus Cho
is really like okay oh you know I'll
probably do a video about that like once
we get around to when the story gets
released I'll do a video on who is
Amadeus Cho because I think a lot of
people have a question about that let
people want to know who he is and so it
makes sense to throw that out there so I
think we're gonna do that I think I'll
do a video on who is Amadeus Cho and so
it'll it'll be you know like the it'll
be you know why he was made the origin
story of Amadeus Cho and then we'll tack
on a third part and say this is why Greg
packets making Amadeus Cho The
Incredible Hulk you know or something
something along those lines so let's see
uh
Channing Tatum is gambit I don't see how
that works you know but I guess it works
enough people are interested so we'll
see what happens
where is Deadpool in Secret Wars he's in
Deadpool secret Secret Wars that's a
whole different thing so anyway guys um
we're gonna go ahead and wrap this this
Q&A up I need to get to work on making
some more videos but yeah I just want to
be like a surprise Q&A I thought it'd be
fun you know hang out with you guys for
a little while and answer some questions
and yeah so I will catch you guys later